if greater than human artificial general
intelligence is invented without due
caution it is all but certain that that
the human species will be extinct in
very short order people have written
extensively about why it is basically
analytically compulsory to conclude that
in the default scenario in the absence
of major surprising developments or
concerted integrated effort in the long
term artificial intelligence will
replace humanity it's the natural or but
inevitable consequence of greater than
human artificial intelligence that it
ought to develop what Steve Omohundro
has called basic AI drives and basic AI
drives basically boils down to
properties of any goal-directed system
the obedience to the von Neumann
Morgenstern decision theory suggests
that one ought to do the things that you
had expect to have the best outcomes
based on some value function and that
value function uniquely specifies some
configuration of matter in the universe
and unless the value function that is
built into an AI implicitly uniquely
specify the configuration of matter in
the universe that conforms to our value
with which we require a great deal of
you know planning to make that happen
then given sufficient power we should
expect an AI to reconfigure the universe
in a manner that does not preserve our
values as far as I can tell this
position is analytically compelling it's
not a position that a person can
intelligently honestly and reasonably be
uncertain about
therefore I conclude that the major
global catastrophic threat to humanity
is not AI but rather the absence of
social intellectual frameworks for
people quickly and easily converging on
analytically compelling conclusions Nick
Bostrom who recently wrote the book
super intelligence machine super
intelligence I believe was aware of the
basic concerns associated with AI risk
twenty years ago and wrote about them
intelligently in a manner that ought to
be sufficiently compelling to convince
any thoughtful and open-minded person
by ten years ago practically everything
that is said in machine intelligence had
been developed into actually into a form
that a person who was more skeptical and
not willing to think for themselves but
who was willing to listen to other
people's thoughts and merely critically
scrutinize it ought to have been
convinced by but instead bassdrum had to
spend ten years more becoming the
director of an incredibly prestigious
Institute and writing a incredibly
rigorous meticulous book in order to get
a still tiny number of people and still
a minority of the world's essentially
most analytically capable people onto
the right page on a topic that is from a
philosophy perspective about as
difficult as Plato's issues in the
Republic about how it's possible for an
object to be bigger than one thing and
smaller than another
even though bigness and smallness are
opposites we are talking about
completely trivial conclusions and we
are talking about the world's greatest
minds failing to
abduct these conclusions when they are
laid out analytically but until an
enormous body of prestige is placed
behind them and as far as I can tell
most of the problems that humanity faces
now and in the future are not going to
be analytically tractable and
analytically compelling the way risk
from AI is analytically tractable and
analytically compelling risks associated
with bio technologies risks associated
with economic issues these sorts of
risks are a lot less likely to cause
human extinction within a few years then
AI but they are more immediate and they
are much much much more complicated the
technical difficulty of creating
institutions that are capable of
thinking about AI risk is so enormous
lehigh compared to the analytical
abilities of existing institutions
demonstrated by existing institutions
failure to reach the trivially correct
easy conclusions about AI risk that
existing institutions are compellingly
not qualified to think about these
issues and ought not to do so but it is
a very high priority for humanity I
think in the long run it is the highest
priority for your mana be that we create
institutions that are capable of
digesting and integrating both logical
argument and empirical evidence and
figuring out what things are important
and true not just in trivial cases like
AI
but in holder cases